[Musik]
die phoenix wahlrunde
was für ein interessanter auftakt ins
superwahljahr 20 21 was sind die
ursachen der ergebnisse von heute und
vor allem wird die bundestagswahl
vielleicht doch spannender als wir
bisher gedacht haben
herzlich willkommen und das sind meine
gäste anna schneider hat den blick von
außen denn sie ist österreicherin und
schreibt die für die schweizer neue
zürcher zeitung heribert prantl ist
autor für die süddeutsche zeitung und
aus münchen zugeschaltet begrüße jan
fleischhauer er ist kolumnist beim focus
herzlich willkommen an sie alle
verbrannte zwei länder zwei wahlen gibt
es trotzdem gemeinsamkeiten
es gibt die gemeinsamkeit dass die
spitzenkandidaten wahnsinnig wichtig
sind bei malu dreyer hat sich etwas
gezeigt was sie in einem buch
geschrieben hat ihre autobiografie trägt
den titel die zukunft ist meine freundin
das hat sich heute gezeigt und für
kretschmann war es ähnlich kretschmann
hat die grünen nach vorn gezogen das
ergebnis der grünen in rheinland pfalz
war gar nicht so blendend aber in
baden-württemberg ist es spektakulär
kretschmann mit den grünen man muss
sagen in erster linie kretschmann hat
der cdu dort den schneid völlig
abgekauft die cdu war mal das
dominierende die dominierende partei in
baden württemberg fast ähnlich wie die
csu in bayern
diese zeiten sind vorbei und heute abend
schaut das fast zu hause werden sie
endgültig vorbei aber das fazit für mich
ist heute tatsächlich es kommt auf die
spitzenkandidaten an die persönlichkeit
von kretschmann die persönlichkeit von
malu dreyer hat diese wahl entschieden
und das sollte auf bundesebene für
september durchaus zu denken geben
frau schneider versehen das auffälligste
an der wahl kurz da gleich noch was
sozusagen
ich glaube nicht dass das nur die
persönlichkeit ist in beiden fällen die
wahl gewonnen hat sondern beide sowohl
kretschmann als auch malu dreyer
verkörpern ja irgendwie in ihren
parteien war es was im bund jetzt nicht
so alltäglich ist also herr kretschmann
irgendwie als der schwarze grüne und
frau dreyer als die pragmatikerin die
jetzt nicht
wie verbringt ist wenn man so in
richtung bundes spd schaut also das
würde ich ein bisschen anders sehen aber
das habe ich sie unterbrochen eigentlich
noch bitte das war doch ihr erster
kommentar zur wahl und jan fleischhauer
manchmal gleich weiter ja ist die
bundestagswahl viel viel spannender als
wir bisher gedacht haben ich lebe ja
schon seit längerem in der angst oder
furcht dass es rot rot grün schaffen
könnte und der axt ich bin dadurch
bestärkt also ich würde sich sagt nach
corona jetzt noch rot-rot-grün im bund
erhält dann können wir in deutschland
wirklich einpacken aber und die die cdu
hat sich bislang so ein bisschen in
sicherheit gewogen hat immer gesagt ja
wir haben diese tollen werte mit 36 37
prozent sind der spd so ganz weit
enteilt wenn man jetzt schon vor zwei
wochen einen geguckt hat so viel hat ja
die beiden lager gar nicht getrennt und
jetzt sieht man eben alles was ist die
was ist die spd cdu wirklich wert also
wenn sie eben nur 30 32 prozent im bund
wert ist dann kann es auch ganz schnell
schief gehen und wir werden ich
verspreche dass in dieser sendung auch
darüber reden ob sie außer rot-rot-grün
auch noch die ampel im bund fürchten da
kommt man gleich darauf aber zunächst
einmal analysieren was da rund um die
cdu passiert ist herbrand baden
württemberg rheinland pfalz das sind
eigentlich klassische cdu stamm länder
wählen auch stramm cdu bei den
bundestagswahlen und in beiden ländern
jetzt noch einmal weiter runter beiden
ländern historisch schlechte ergebnisse
was ist da passiert
das zeigt doch und bestätigt meine these
es bestätigte these dass die
spitzenkandidaten und die persönlichkeit
der jeweiligen ministerpräsidenten
wirklich sehr sehr sehr wichtig ist so
aber heißt es aus ihrer sicht dass das
gar nicht so schlimm ist für die cdu
weil sie an diesen populären
ministerpräsidenten gescheitert sind
oder ist da doch was richtig schief ist
natürlich auch an sich selbst
gescheitert man muss ja alles auch sehen
die cdu stand in rheinland pfalz zum
beispiel noch vor wenigen wochen ganz
gut da da hat die bundespolitik da haben
die vorgänge um nüßlein und co
hereingespielt hat die korona politik
hereingespielt
und man hat ja lange geglaubt corona
würde der cdu würde der merkel partei
ersparen partei unglaublich helfen aber
es zeigt sich in den letzten wochen
wer mit corona der schöne spruch mit dem
aufzug dance aus anderen zusammenhängen
gibt ja mit corona den aufzug hinauf
fährt der fährt mit krone auch wieder
herunter cdu und die cdu ist jetzt
herunter gefahren des impfstoffs da hat
ja wahnsinnig geschadet
und da hat die bundespolitik auf die
landespolitik durchgeschlagen in
rheinland pfalz kommt hinzu dass der
spitzenkandidat baum auf einfach wegen
der besonderheiten eines corona
wahlkampfes nicht die möglichkeit hat
sich richtig bekanntzumachen man muss
wirklich sehen das wäre auch für den
bundestagswahlkampf eine rolle spielen
der klassische wahlkampf den man kennt
wird so nicht stattfinden können und es
wird keine großen kundgebung
kundgebungen geben es wird dann haustür
wahlkampf nicht geben außer wir erleben
noch das im sommer auf einmal dem verein
viel viel besser funktioniert wir jetzt
und corona plötzlich verschwindet wird
nicht dabei sein
wir werden einen wahlkampf erleben wie
sie ihnen dieser sonderheit noch nie
gegeben hat der wahlkampf ist so
unberechenbar wie noch nie und auch das
wahlergebnis ist so unberechenbar wie
nie
wahlkampf zu kroner zeiten funktioniert
für mich ein bisschen wie die fahrt mit
der geisterbahn werden man weiß nicht
welche das gespenst hinter der nächsten
kurve auftaucht und das gilt jetzt sind
wir wieder bei der cdu für beide
potenziellen kanzlerkandidaten das gilt
für laschet und für söder man weiß nicht
was passiert in nrw was man weiß nicht
was passiert in bayern
die situation ist höchst unkalkulierbar
und darin liegt spannenden von dem sie
reden wie sie genau hin was sind die
populären ministerpräsidenten welchen
anteil haben die anderen niederlage der
cdu was die massen affäre
und was ist eine veritable cdu krise
insgesamt also ich glaube man muss
zuerst überhaupt bei abwarten erstens
auch was das briefwahlstimmen
unterbringen und ich glaube schon dass
die cdu in ziemlichen image-verlust habt
durch diese masken affäre weil das
vertrauen dass dadurch schwindet
natürlich bei den wählern dieses dieses
bild vom raffgierigen politiker das ist
natürlich geil
in ihrer partei schädlich trotzdem sind
es zwei punkte erstens stand die cdu
auch wenn herbei doch eigentlich gute
zahlen hatte in beiden ländern jetzt
also beiden ländern wo es gewinn wurde
nicht so besonders gut da also auch ohne
diese masken affäre glaube ich dass es
nicht so hervorragend ausgegangen wäre
aber was eben dazu kommt und was ich
eben auch sehr viel stärker gewichten
würde ist wie die cdu als gesamtes in
dieser krise da steht also das bonmot
von frau merkel im großen ganzen ist
nichts schief gelaufen wie sie
vielleicht heute nicht noch mal
wiederholen sie hat sich glaube ich noch
nicht geäußert aber das sieht man eben
dass diese stunde der regierung von der
man lange geredet hat also ein ganzes
jahr lang um genau zu sein
die ist jetzt wirklich vorbei also ist
man sieht ja auch wie schnell mal fallen
kann am beispiel von jens spahn der
einfach nicht mehr vorkommt herr
fleischer ist auffallend dass heute
weder angela merkel noch der
parteivorsitzende lasche dieses
wahlergebnis kommentieren wollten wird
das so bleiben vielleicht haben sie noch
keine zeit gefunden und müssen erst mal
verdauen
ich weiß nicht ich glaube nicht
vorstellen dass die kanzlerin jetzt so
auf dauer verschwindet wobei sie hat ja
eine gewisse jetzt taktik so entwickelt
in interviews zu sagen alles läuft bombe
und design mit sich im reinen vielleicht
schafft sie das auch in den nächsten
wochen also ich habe das nicht ganz
überzeugt dass das ist die masken affäre
sei ja ich glaube wer also ich bin dann
eher bei brandl wenn also wenn ich in
rheinland pfalz leben und ich hab die
auswahl zwischen malu dreyer gegen die
doch eigentlich kein mensch was sagen
kann super netter super sympathische
frau macht einen guten job und so einen
unbekannten mann von der cdu
da musst du schon sehr sehr sehr an die
cdu glauben um dann cdu zu wählen und
das ähnlich ist doch auch in baden
württemberg kretschmann ist natürlich
super aus sicht der leute ein grüner der
die automobil-industrie schützt ja das
ist dass das dass die ideale kombination
so und jakob natürlich schon gar nicht
so eine frau wie ich weiß gar nicht
verreisen man die auch mal so ein
bisschen verkniffen aussieht unser
denkorgan kommen rohrstock gleichzeitig
über ja auch im bildungs das hat ja das
bildungsressort unter sich ich glaube
das ist also ist ja auch interessant wie
unterschiedlich die ergebnisse beiden
ländern sind ich meine das weiß doch
darauf
dass es vielleicht wir den wir lieben
das als journalisten immer natürlich den
großen bundes effekt da jetzt reicht's
zu geheimnissen
aber möglicherweise ist der viel
geringer ich meine die spd mein land
steht klasse da ja mit malu dreyer und
in dem anderen das werden wir jetzt
sehen wie schlecht wenn es ganz schief
läuft ist die fünfte partei also auf
platz fünf noch hinter afd
und und und fdp also da sieht man ja wie
auch wie groß die ausschläge sind ich
glaube das ist wirklich zu erklären nur
durch letztlich regionale unternehmen
wir haben mal bei der spd ganz
unterschiedliche ergebnisse wir haben
sozusagen sozialdemokratische
ungleichzeitigkeiten und wir haben
christdemokratische gleichzeitigkeit der
cdu geht es in beiden ländern schlecht
und ansonsten bei der spd hat man dann
den eindruck es gibt zwei verschiedene
sozialdemokratische parteien eine die
von malu dreyer geführt wird und in
rheinland-pfalz der kids glänzend unter
anderem partei derweil schon gar nicht
wieder spitzenkandidat heißt die
irgendwo bei 10% herumkrebst ein
desaster haben wir 22
sozialdemokratische parteien und wenn ja
was folgt daraus
wer bin ich und wenn ja wie viele ist
eine gute frage für die spd aber da
haben sie ja noch einen sitz
rausgelassen zwar die bundes spd
sie musste er vorher sehr schmunzeln als
risken sich als wort gemeldet hat für
diese großartige wahl und dann meinte so
sieht man sieht wie die spd wahlen
gewinnen kann und man kann sich dazu
denken ja ganz genau so nicht also so
wie es die bundes-spd gerade macht also
wenn man letzten wochen beobachtet hat
die internen grabenkämpfe wo man sich
nicht mal insofern zusammenraffen kann
dass man irgendwie wolfgang thierse da
irgendwie noch mit nimmt als alten als
alte garde
das ist schon das fleisch out zu sagen
man kann daraus sicher nicht dass dem
bundestrend jetzt ablesen
aber das liegt noch mal an diesen beiden
personen die ihr irgendwie also sowohl
kretschmann als auch als auch drei er
diese pragmatiker in ihrer partei sind
die einfach nicht im bund so
repräsentiert sind also bei den grünen
ist vielleicht hab ich und werbung sind
die lassen vermutlich mit sich reden
wenn sie auch sicher irgendwie bis ihre
radikalen ansichten haben aber da gibt's
schon nach hardcore linke natürlich im
punkt und über die kann man dann drüber
der kanzlerkandidat ist betrieb ist
nicht gerade ein fundamentalist auch mit
pragmatismus lässt sich nicht immer ein
erfolg erklären in dem fall kann man
sagen die malu dreyer ist pragmatikerin
aber sie seien ja eine pragmatikerin der
besonderen art sie hat ausstrahlung sie
hat das gewisse etwas und der
kretschmann für den gilt das vielleicht
am ersten weil er ein ungewöhnlicher
grüner ist weil er die tüten hat die
nicht unbedingt zum klassischen alten
mainstream der grünen gehören in dieser
sendung ist es ausnahmsweise mal ein
standort nachteil wenn man in münchen
ist deswegen herr fleischhauer ihr müsst
nach zu wort kommen wir wollten was
sagen das ist übrigens nicht nur in
dieser sendung so ich glaube markus
söder sieht das schon seit längerem so
dass deswegen deswegen drängt er sich ja
auch in jeder in jeder jeder gelegenheit
nach vorne und redet dann doppelt so
lange wie die kanzlerin oder der chef
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ja was
zeigt uns das ergebnis das ergebnis
zeigt uns natürlich auch dass man
gewinnt ein programm der mitte also frau
schneider hat ja gerade hingewiesen
frau s jetzt sagt ja das sind die themen
mit denen man gewinnt das habe malu
dreyer jedoch gezeigt ist sich
wahnsinnig komisch weil womit hat frau
esther letzten wochen zugebracht darüber
nachzudenken wie man menschen anspricht
die sich nicht entscheiden können ob sie
man über frau sind und wer die falsch
anspricht kriegt einen bösen brief aus
der parteizentrale wie die zum beispiel
chefin der grundwertekommission frau
schwan die gesagt du hast mich geändert
und darum wieder total peinlich wir
schämen uns so für dich ja das ist
möglicherweise nicht das programm kann
man nur sagen mit stäben die ärzten der
wähler gewinnt malu dreyer mit beiden
beinen auf dem boden stehen und auch
letztlich so zu reden dass die leute ein
verstehen und interessanterweise
übrigens vor dreier in der korona krise
hat auch mal wieder erkennen lassen dass
sie mit dem kurs der kanzlerin nicht
ganz so einverstanden ist also dieses
super lock down logo wird zero wird er
das hat die nie mitgemacht und
möglicherweise ist auch dass ein kurs
wer sich bei so einer landtagswahl
auszahlt dass die leute das gefühl haben
naja das ist also alles radikale ist
dann auch ein weg ins unglück
vielleicht erklärt sich so auch mit dem
was fleisch aber eben sorgt für doch
durchaus respektable erfolg der fdp der
fdp hat lange gebraucht bis sie das
getan hat was eigentlich ihre aufgabe
ist die freiheitsrechte zu verteidigen
sie war in der ersten bundestags-debatte
von beschämender schwäche wenn ich mich
an die rede von christian lindner
erinnern damals ich dachte mein gott du
bist ein freidemokrat
ihr habt große rechtsstaatliche
traditionen zu verteidigen
wo sind die eigentlich und ich glaube
wenn ich das richtig beobachte auch die
umfragen die umfragen für die fdp sind
gestiegen auch die heutigen
wahlergebnisse mit ihrem einsteigen und
mit ihrem eintreten für die bürgerrechte
und für die freiheitsrechte
es war doch erbärmlich dass sich die afd
diese bürgerrechte ansehen konnte wir in
tarnanzug dass die sich im bundestag
hinstellt und sagt wir verteidigen die
bürgerrechte da fällt ihm der griffel
aus der hand wenn man weiß wie die
ansonsten zu grundrechten stehen aber
ich glaube und das ist auch eine
erkenntnis aus dieser wahl vielleicht
aber hat sie ihm gesagt für malu dreyer
es zahlt sich aus wenn man in diesen
schwierigen zeiten für die grundrechte
die grundrechte betont aber aller bei
aller bei aller bei aller einsicht in
die gefährlichkeit von corona aber es
ist nicht so dass man möglichst viele
grundrechte abräumen mussum corona
erfolgreich zu bekämpfen
was ist ihnen lieber herr brandt uhr im
haus anderes stichwort fdp war das ist
eigentlich in die die spannendste partei
in diesem in diesen beiden
landtagswahlen jetzt also konnten in
beiden ländern dazugewinnen in baden
württemberg sogar gut also zweistellig
jetzt und liebäugeln so einige schon
also mit der ampel koalition nach einem
fall schaut so aus als wird sie
fortgesetzt klar vielleicht auch in
baden württemberg wenn herr kretschmann
nicht mehr mit den katzen mag nur da
jetzt schon jetzt wird natürlich der
linken auch ständig gefragt und wie
schaut's aus macht man das im bund auch
und da ist genau das was sie vorher
schon gesagt habe
im bund sind die zwei anderen ampel
parteien halt schon was anderes als wenn
man sich die spd und die grünen anstatt
im bund ob das sich mit herrn lindner
ausgeht also da ist die die fdp schon
eben viel mehr diese freiheitspartei und
das würde ich mal nicht fahren zu nehmen
für den bund lassen sie uns doch mal bei
diesem interessanten stichwort appell
also spd mit fdp und grünen bleiben
herr brandl ist das eine realistische
option für den bund weil das in
rheinland-pfalz offensichtlich von
wähler bestätigt wurde und in baden
württemberg zumindest eine option ist es
könnte sich anbahnen aber ich sage das
was wir schon eingangs betont hatten es
ist momentan wirklich schwer in den
september zuschauen
die nächsten monate sind wirklich
unkalkulierbar
aber ich glaube die bereitschaft der fdp
bei der nächsten koalitionsverhandlungen
wenn es sich so fügt der koalition näher
zu treten als beim letzten mal die sehr
viel größer lindner wird koste es was es
wolle schauen dass er in die regierung
kommt und der image verluste beim
letzten mal erlitten hat mit einem sehr
ungeschickten taktieren einem sehr
ungeschickten aussteigen aus den
koalitionsverhandlungen das würde kein
zweites mal mehr passieren
vielleicht habe wie schätzen sie das ein
also die fdp hat in baden württemberg
gesagt die ampel ist der option in
rheinland-pfalz ampel sie bereits ist
das auch eine option für den bund sowie
schon klar also sagen wir diese also die
die liebe zur cdu ist ja nun erkennbar
erkaltet dafür hat die bundeskanzlerin
ja auch alles getan als er noch
parteivorsitzende war und also ja jede
gelegenheit auch genutzt
die fdp unter zufügen wir erinnern uns
als die fdp aus dem bundestag geflogen
war hat gröhe gesungen und hat gefühlt
keinen tag so wunderschön wie heute
das hat kein kein liberaler vergessen ja
also wie man sozusagen noch auf dem grab
rumgetrampelt ist und derjenige der
damals an
rufen hat bei christian lindner aus dem
auto um ihm zu sagen wir mal auf das tut
mir echt leid das war interessanterweise
jürgen trittin ich glaube die
bundeskanzlerin hat dann zwei tage
später mal angerufen war nicht so schön
das sind ausgefallen seien
diese wurden der sommer die sitzt so
tief erklärt übrigens auch so ein
bisschen worum es dann im zweiten anlauf
der fdp so schwer gefallen ist in diese
koalition einzutreten die merkel ihr
angeboten hatte und insofern also statt
mit kommt immer darauf an also ich meine
wie links dann die spd ist und wie links
die grünen aber es ist auf jeden fall
gibt es diese babylonische
gefangenschaft
also wir trotz als liberale an der seite
der cdu gibt es nicht mehr im gegenteil
das würde der fdp einen höllenspaß
machen ein bisschen auch an wäre dann
der bundeskanzler ist wäre das
wahrscheinlich dann an den er bei
blogger die viel zu schreiben als
kolumnist für mich eine schöne variante
also den mal sozusagen den stinkefinger
zu zeigen bei der 10
jetzt halten wir mal fest der zeit geben
ja die umfragen noch keine mehrheit für
spd mit fdp und grünen er aber man muss
ja nur den sinkflug der cdu ein bisschen
in die zukunft fortschreiben dann könnte
plötzlich eine ganz neue option auf dem
tisch liegen über die mir bisher bis zu
diesem alter überhaupt nicht gesprochen
haben und was bedeutet das ich glaube
auch wenn sie jetzt theoretisch oder
rechnerisch möglich wäre noch immer dass
die wahrscheinlichkeit aber
wahrscheinlich eine variante wäre dass
die grünen sich bei den schwarzen
andocken weil was er vielleicht hat
ausgeführt hat dieses diese
babylonischer gefangenschaft quasi
zwischen diesen beiden die ist ja nicht
nur abgekühlt die beziehung ist nicht
abgekühlt als sie aus dem bundestag
fliegen sondern wenn wir erinnern uns
dass herr söder in letzter zeit
eigentlich nur mehr grün am abend hat
oder herr brinkhaus ordentlich
ausgeteilt in richtung fdp
auch als die sich über krone maßnahmen
beschwert hatten
also das ist ja frische wunde sozusagen
trotzdem glaube ich auch und da werde
ich ganz mannheim brand wenn ich sage
dass das herr lindner alles fast geben
würde man die regierung zu gehen
ich glaube da wird sich davor hüten wenn
es schon bei schwarz-grün gescheitert
ist wie soll sich das mit rot-grün
ausgehen man hat ja immer immer gesagt
das war ein fehler dass die fdp
nicht in die koalition eingetreten ist
im moment hat es den eindruck als ob
sich das ein bisschen endet weil jetzt
kriegen sie nichts ab von diesem chor
überdruss und corona frust und natürlich
nichts was herr linden irgendwie
voraussehen konnte jetzt nutzte simons
die art und weise jetzt vorhergesagt wie
er jetzt bürgerrechte verteidigen kann
nutzt ihm in dieser krise und er ist die
vertritt die demo eigentlich auch mal
die die gene der fdp dass meine
bürgerrechte vertrete das ist etwas was
ich mir von dieser partei hofft dort wo
sie relativ lange anlauf genommen haben
um das zu tun was ihr gemäß ist jetzt
tut hier ist und das zweite ich glaube
ich für sie wenn sie in die regierung
gegangen wäre damals hätte sie sich
damit jetzt um einiges schwerer
imageschaden war es trotzdem nicht
voraussehbaren das ist so kommt herr
brand herr fleischer brand hat in
wahrheit ja heimlich ein fdp parteibuch
schon in der schublade liegen er hat ja
ein buch geschrieben kann ich ja mal an
der stelle empfehlen wenn er sich selber
machen will ja das flammende
verteidigung der bürgerrechte doch ist
ein fabelhaftes buch ehrlich gesagt
haben ihre regen zogen fleischhauer buch
empfehlen ja das kommt mittlerweile dann
aber in der in der korona zeit mal sagen
als linker die stimme erhoben
wie kann es eigentlich sein das übrigens
auch gerade jetzt in diesem fall von von
linken jedes bürgerrecht weggeräumt wird
ja außer dem datenschutz der ist uns ja
eigentlich ja da ist uns an den darf
nicht gerührt werden aber alle sonst
bürgerrechte zur seite geschoben werden
und ein flammendes plädoyer gehalten
das nicht zu übertreiben also dieser art
von notstandsregierung die vereine mehr
haben denn irgendwelche
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz die gar
nicht im grundgesetz vorgesehen sind
sofern und die partei kitas zögerlich
aber auch immer wieder artikuliert ist
eben die fdp insofern hatte sich
möglicherweise ganz wacker geschlagen
und interessant über die parteien jedoch
gar nicht geredet
für die sich das überhaupt nicht
ausgezahlt hat ist die afd
weil ich glaube dass die afc wiederum
mit ihrem kurs er sich zur kasperle
truppe gemacht hat also eine partei die
ernsthaft ja ein rechtsanwalt losschickt
um den bundestagspräsidenten an schäuble
dazu zwingen dass er die masten pflicht
im bundestag aufhebt da sagen die leute
ihr habt sie doch nicht mehr alle
und insofern da haben wir jetzt also das
glaube ich da fließen die wasser so ein
bisschen ab wie immer man zu artig steht
einige werden das mit natürlich mit
großer befriedigung sehen aber das wird
glaube ich für die partei sind die
aussichten eher düster was die bundes-
noch mal erhöht werden weil sie ist
erkennt man nicht schafft diesen zorn
und die wut und die enttäuschung und die
ist ja auch gibt da sind relativ viele
leute in deutschland getroffen natürlich
von den corona maßnahmen jeder der sein
kleines schuhgeschäft hat da stehen wir
mit dem mit dem rücken zur wand aber die
ft ft ist erkennbar nicht die option für
diese leute kenne ich das stichwort mal
aufgreifen ist das abschneiden der fdp
an diesem wörtern wirklich so schlecht
vorstellen also eine flasche jetzt grade
von der bundesebene gesprochen
eigentlich aber was die landtags
ergebnisse also landtagswahlergebnis
jetzt angeht sind sie zumindest nicht
schlecht und das ist obwohl die idee
eben in corona zeiten nicht sehr viel zu
bringen hat oder auch mit sehr vielen
punkten konnte und der tatsache dass
verfassungsschutz die eigentlich jetzt
bald beobachten könnte sollte wollte ist
eigentlich gar nicht also dass sie nicht
wirklich abgesunken sind erkennt man
schon dass da irgendwie eine basis für
sie da ist und die nicht weg ist
vielleicht vielleicht wäre ohne dieses
wie ich meine frische eintreten für die
bürgerrechte
der absturz deutlicher ausgefallen
die iaa ist deutlich zurückgegangen ich
hatte mir eigentlich wartet sie geht
noch stärker zurück bei den letzten
landtagswahlen weil wir mitten in der
debatte über flüchtlinge es war das
wasser auf die mühlen der afd
die konstellationen für die afg waren
damals ungeheuer günstig jetzt waren die
rahmenbedingungen schlecht für die
schlechten rahmenbedingungen steht sie
immer noch ziemlich gut da
gut 10 10 prozent plus ist für mich ein
ergebnis für eine rechtsaußen partei das
nicht tolerabel ist ich glaube nicht
dass die verfassungsschutz beobachtungen
die er noch keine richtige beobachtung
ist eine entscheidende rolle gespielt
hat da war das juristische hin und her
viel zu groß
ich bin der meinung dass die beobachtung
richtig ist aber man muss sie juristisch
ordentlich aufziehen und ordentlich
einfädeln dass bei der fdp gibt es so
eine art brauchen spannte sie
zusammenhält das ist die art und weise
wie sie über den nationalsozialismus
redet wie ihre spitzen figuren über die
ns-zeit reden das ist völlig intolerant
für eine für ein demokratisches land mit
dieser geschichte
da wünsche ich mir tatsächlich dass der
verfassungsschutz ein starkes auge drauf
hat aber es hatte diese beobachtung
wahrscheinlich auf diese wahlen noch
keinen entscheidenden einfluss
die flüchtlingskrise hat im letzten jahr
durch die korona krise so gut wie keine
rolle gespielt trotzdem ist die afd in
beiden ländern um die zehn prozent
kämpft in beiden ländern um platz drei
also die kfd ist zumindest noch da genau
also das mag schon stimmen dass jetzt
diese verfassungsschutz vater noch nicht
so hundertprozentig darauf eingezahlt
hat aber es klingt schon etwas mit den
bürgern wenn sie hören afd
verfassungsschutz beobachtung also das
ist ein bisschen unruhe macht glaube ich
schon deswegen noch mal bin ich eher
verwundert über diese überhaupt 10 plus
prozent das ist nicht aus wenn ich also
ja ich war ehrlich sagt der staunt
darüber
ich würde gerne herr fleischhauer einen
namen ins spiel bringen denn sie vorhin
im zusammenhang mit münchen erwähnt
haben und zwar ist das markus söder mit
mit welchen gefühlen sitzt er denn jetzt
im moment zu hause darf der sich über
dieses wahlergebnis freuen weil es
zumindest nicht gut ist für laschet
kurzweiligen stimmt tatsächlich also
armin laschet ist ja wirklich gerade ein
unglücklicher mann der noch nicht
irgendwie wirklich an der spitze steht
da war schon an der spitze steht muss
dieses wahlergebnis obwohl also ich ja
schon im vorfeld quasi davon distanziert
oder in einem welt -interview gesagt
angesprochen darauf was das bedeutet was
das ergebnis ist aber allen denn
bedeutet meinte ja gar nix so quasi also
er hat sich schon im vorfeld davon
distanziert glaube ich gut für ihn weil
es wird nicht an ihm so haften
trotzdem ist markus söder davon noch
irgendwie ganz weit entfernt aber ich
nehme an auch deswegen verhält dass ich
einigermaßen ruhig weil das irgendwie
ausgleichende gerechtigkeit in dieser
masken affäre dass cdu und cdu
abgeordnete gleichermaßen betroffen sind
also cdu also die ganze union tut
eigentlich gerade gut daran was sie auch
wirklich tut da für transparenz zu
sorgen und auch die flucht nach vorne
anzutreten was ist dies transparenz
regis diese ehrenerklärungen die der
freitagabend eingetrudelt ist aufkam
also ich glaube markus söder hält gerade
bisschen die füße still weil da ein
bisschen gras wachsen muss man muss auch
sehen dagegen kandidat volker schütz war
friedrich merz stellen wir uns mal ganz
kurz vor friedrich merz wäre
parteivorsitzender geworden in dieser
zeit der dieser dieser masken affäre
man sagt jetzt transparenz muss her die
nebeneinkünfte müssen viel penibler
offengelegt werden märz gehörte zu den
klägern gegen die regelung und die
offenlegung der nebeneinkünfte in
karlsruhe er gehörte zu denen die sagt
es geht niemanden was an
wenn jetzt nerz vorsitzender wäre stünde
die cdu wirklich ziemlich komisch in der
landschaft und der stadt hat pech er
kann überhaupt nichts für dieses
wahlergebnis für diese wahlergebnisse in
baden württemberg und rheinland pfalz er
setzt seit 50 tagen parteivorsitzender
aber man sagt heute er hat einen
unglücklichen start und eigentlich man
redet immer von der großen konkurrenz
zwischen söder und laschet eigentlich
ist er der kanzlerkandidat
die cdu könnte einpacken wenn sie ihren
neuen vorsitzenden sofort wieder
abräumen würden und sagen dann muss
jetzt wieder ihr da müssen noch ganz
andere fehler gemacht werden da musste
doch ganz anderes passieren um laschet
als kanzlerkandidaten wegzuwischen
herr fleischer wie viel von diesen
niederlagen bleibt dann laschet hängen
gut aus dem block man wünscht sich
natürlich bei einem parteivorsitzenden
wir mal wieder cdu ist dass er vor tun
hat und verdient hat er bislang nicht
es läuft halt alles alles schief corona
management läuft schief kann er jetzt
nicht für so viel für diese komische
masken affäre
und dann ist auch die beiden
landtagswahlen einerseits andererseits
die frage aufgeworfen was heißt das
jetzt für die spitzenkandidatur also
erstens will ich sagen
markus das ein sehr vorsichtiger mensch
er hat ja immer dieses rabauken und
image ja und man denkt so deckt den geht
gleich die tür
tatsächlich seien sehr vorsichtiger die
die umstände sehr wohl kalkulieren der
politiker und da würde sich in keinem
fall in eine schlacht stürzen vor den
eindruck hat dass die cdu nicht richtig
mitzieht
das haben sie ja nun zweimal lebt in
bayern ja einmal ganz ganz schlimm bei
franz josef strauß den hat die cdu
verhungern lassen dann hat ja auch das
entsprechende ergebnis dann eingesetzt
auch beim stoiber war die cdu setzt sich
wirklich toll im wald habe ich dabei das
wird er sich ersparen
und ich glaube der einzige weg der für
markus söder ins kanzleramt für pc in
die spitzenkandidatur ist dass die bei
der cdu so nervös werden und so den
glauben verlieren an armin laschet im
nächsten wochen dass sie eben dass sie
den laschen selber beiseite räumen und
das dem sie daran tragen weil halt das
wird so sein
seine umfragewerte werden vermutlich
erst mal deutlich besser ausfallen als
die von armin laschet weil natürlich
sagen er hatte zu diesem führung
ausstrahlt und und anderes mehr
mitbringt was dir was da laschet so mit
seiner etwas kalkuliert sein das spiel
sondern dies ein bisschen dies ein
bisschen jedes jahr ist ausgleichende
das wird eben sehr viel schwerer glaubt
laschet nicht unterschätzen laschet ist
jemand der ein guter teamplayer ist der
macht streitigkeiten gut ausbalancieren
kann
es fragt sich ob das die gaben sind die
in den nächsten wochen zum zuge kommen
werden wenn an stoiber erinnert wird
dann erinnere ich mich auch an die
szenen seiner zeit wie stoiber in
parteitage der cdu eingezogen ist das
war ein getan fällt es war eine stimmung
es wurde er wurde gefeiert
dass schüler jetzt auf dem parteitag der
cdu so gefeiert wird
kann ich mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen
dh die cdu ist nicht bereit dafür die
kanzlerkandidatur an so dazu übergehen
ob jetzt ist sie noch nicht bereit da
müsste noch einiges an schlimmen dingen
passieren da müsste laschet wirklich den
nächsten wochen vom pech ganz kolossal
verfolgt sein
wer wäre denn der bessere kanzler
kandidat für die union laschet oder so
da besser ist schwierige frage also dass
das kann ich so oder will ich gar nicht
zu beantworten
ich glaube ich glaube auch dass man die
nachrichten geschützt unterschätzen darf
aber also einen anderen grund irgendwie
also der held ja anders als zum beispiel
dem jetzt friedrich merz geworden wäre
wirklich die partei doch irgendwie
zusammen also im einsatz farblosigkeit
vor und irgendwie als merkel janow kann
ich beides verstehen anteilig auch die
ansicht trotzdem ist er der angenehmere
kandidat für diese ganze truppe eben
stellen wir uns vor friedrich merz wäre
es geworden ist unvorstellbar und markus
söder da glaube ich auch nicht dass der
in die erste reihe steht wird aber aus
er dem grund dass der auch viel zu sehr
polarisiert glaube ich zumindest also
durch eben diese sehr autoritäre art der
fährt in der korona krise das kommt zwar
so als landesfürst gut an aber ich
glaube nicht dass das das ganze land mit
trägt also im zweifel glaube ich
entscheidet man sich oder ist auch der
ganzen union lieber den gemäßigteren zu
haben was das dann bedeutet für die
bundestagswahlen lobte dann auch
wirklich die stimmen holen kann
die vielleicht ein löwe zu wiederholen
könnte diese anfrage wie lange kann sich
die union denn überhaupt noch zeit lässt
für diese entscheidung über sagt sie
will zwischen ostern und pfingsten
entscheiden nämlich das sagen ja auch
die grünen wollen auch zwischen ostern
und pfingsten sich an schnell
entscheiden
irgendwann wird die harte phase des
wahlkampfs beginnen im juni juli
bis dahin wird man ihn haben müssen und
bis dahin haben wir noch einige
unkalkulierbarkeit wir haben über drei
alternativen gesprochen die
mehrheitsfähig sein könnten für die
bundestagswahlen dass es schwarz grün
dann ist es plötzlich jetzt die ampel
und natürlich ist immer noch rot rot
grün im spiel da fällt auf eine partei
ist immer dabei und das sind die grünen
und die sind ja auch
so was wie der gewinner dieser wahl geht
nichts mehr ohne grüne die künftige
stabile regierungspartei wenn man das
schicksal der grünen sieht dann muss man
sich auch fragen ist das wort
volkspartei der ja gern sagen wenn wir
von der cdu csu reden von der spd redet
niemand mehr als volkspartei ist das
reden von volksparteien überhaupt noch
richtig sind nicht mittlerweile die
demokratischen parteien allesamt
volksparteien damit auch die grünen
früher war sie also man hat sich die
parteienlandschaft vorstellen können in
alten zeiten der republik wenn die
deutsche kleinfamilie da war mutter und
vater das war die spd und cdu/csu und da
waren die kinder das waren die kleineren
parteien
dieses modell ist endgültig vorbei das
war die alte bundesrepublik die kleinen
parteien sind größer geworden
die großen parteien sind kleiner
geworden das gilt auch für die cdu
daraus ergeben sich ganz neue
konstellationen und die erste ist die
die sie ansprechen dass die grünen in
jeder denkbaren konstellation derzeit
dabei sind die grünen der große gewinner
dieses wahltages und vielleicht
überhaupt des wahljahres 20 21 schon ein
bisschen der pandabär deutsche politik
alle mögen die außer wenigen stimmt die
dagegenhalten
das ist das center ist gut schwarz-grün
da würde ich sagen die sagen die leute
der bomben bomben kombination also ein
christdemokratischer kanzler und der ein
bisschen so eben diesen weichen kurs
dann fahren kann mit den grünen die dann
was ich dies und jenes ressort bekommen
was ganz anderes wäre es ja das macht
die leute sich nicht so ganz klar sagen
man hat meiner eingangs schreck vision
ja wir haben rot-rot-grün war bei rot
rot grün ist ja völlig falsch
ausgedrückt also wenn es dazu kommt dass
ein linkes bündnis durchregiert dann ist
ein grün rot rotes bündnis also mit
entweder herr frau beer berg oder herren
habe als bundeskanzler
das stellt die leute sich natürlich gar
nicht vor wenn sie ein kreuz bei den
grünen machen wenn man sie die das
fragen würde wollt ihr die wirklich
haben als kanzler ich glaube da würden
sich viele leute sagen nochmal drüber
nachdenke sagt will ich wirklich dass
alle niederberg kanzlerin in deutschland
wird oder robert robert habeck ja der
mann der seine nachmittag damit zu
bringen sich von ponys streicheln
das ist also wie schnuppern zu lassen in
einem land das doch oder wo er mal sehen
die gibt die hinterlassenschaft dieser
regierung für den nächsten kanzler ist
dass ich eine ganz ganz schwere also im
augenblick narkotisieren wir das land
mit geld alle programme ja auch so
ausgelegt dass sie über den wahltag
hinaus reichen also kurzarbeitergeld
verlängert bis januar 2022
das insolvenzrecht dahingehend geändert
dass also bis oktober keine insolvenz
anmelden muss aber das bleibt natürlich
nicht so und das heißt die das ist das
werk eine schwere bürde die den nächsten
kanzler erwarten wird weil dann auch die
ökonomischen folgen dieser operation
dieses dauer lockten sie haben jetzt
zwölf monate von 12 monaten sind wir
jetzt im siebten monat noch dauern
das hat natürlich enorme auswirkungen
auf die volkswirtschaft und das wird
deutlich werden im nächsten jahr
spätestens aber so und ich glaube aber
das vertrauen dann bei aller liebe zu
den grünen dass die das hinkriegen als
kanzler und kanzlerin mit all den
beschreibungen haben sie ja recht wenn
es darum geht wer ist denn kanzler für
die kammer sv bernburg zutrauen kann man
es ja weg zu trauen
erinnern wir uns daran wie wir angela
merkel eingeschätzt haben vor langer
langer zeit kaum jemand überhaupt
niemand auch aus denn aus unserer
branche hat angela merkel damals eine
solche regierungszeit wie immer man
jetzt das ende beurteilt zugetraut und
warum soll man nicht auch einer grünen
noch jung gerät berät als damals angela
merkel war
warum sollte man jetzt nicht zutrauten
die wahl in baden-württemberg hat auch
gezeigt dass sich sogar bürgerlich
konservative wähler einen grünen
regierungschef vorstellen können wenn er
denn ist wie
winfried kretschmann können die grünen
im bund kretschmann in irgendeiner art
und weise zum vorbild dem oder zerbricht
dann die partei das ist genau der punkt
also es kann schon sein dass an einem
berg weil ich glaube ich würde mal
darauf vertrauen dass sie kanzlerin
würde von den beiden aber das ist eine
meiner vermutung dann wird kein dorthin
wenn sie sich das gott du bist ein kleid
von überstunden würde das kann schon
funktionieren ich denke auch dass wir
das machen würde aber dann ist geht er
halt ging er hat große teile der partei
verloren
und wir sprechen uns nur von den grünen
bei seinem auch für mich der horror
rot-rot-grün im bund bündnis aber was
die beiden roten parteien wollen in den
parteiprogrammen haben das ist ja noch
ganz was anderes also wenn man sich
überlegt die linke in die koalition zu
holen was dem programm stehen haben
alleine beginnen wir bei den
außenpolitischen vorstellungen die die
haben das geht sich eigentlich mit
niemandem aus und deswegen bin ich
eigentlich ein bisschen beruhigt weil
ich mir nicht vorstellen kann dass das
wirklich gemacht und da übrigens wäre ja
auch noch wahrscheinlicher und da hatten
wir noch immer den grünen kanzler wenn
es im bund eine ampel gebe also ich
glaube dass rot-rot-grün davon
wahrscheinlicher ist als eine ampel
man muss man etwas sagen weil wir heute
vom erfolg von malu dreyer reden halo 3
er bezeichnet sich selber als linke-
politikerin warum weil sie auf soziale
gerechtigkeit auch im wahlkampf in
diesem wahlkampf von dem letzten
wahlkampf vor vier jahren viel wert
gelegt hat das ist schon etwas was bei
grün rot rot wichtig sein könnte der
ganze bereich der sozialen gerechtigkeit
wie gehe ich mit der spaltung im lande
um wie gehe ich damit um dass viele
ärmer werden das ist ein ur
sozialdemokratisches andere anliegen und
mit diesem anliegen können sie natürlich
bei der anderen roten partei anpacken
aber wir sind die konstellation jetzt
noch zu früh um über solche dinge zu
reden
ein punkt zeigt war vielleicht doch ganz
kurz an sprechen das ist etwas ganz
kleines in rheinland pfalz sind die
freien wähler die freiheitsrechte ganz
eine ganz eigene partei eine partei die
aus kommunalen wählergruppen
hervorgegangen ist den bayern bei der
letzten landtagswahl immer in 11,6
prozent hatte die in bayern in der
regierung setzt der bundesvorsitzende
über die wange ist bayerischer
wirtschaftsminister da ist ein bisschen
musik drin auch für eine
bundespolitische debatte was was suchen
denn die wähler bei den freien wählern
was sie bei den etablierten parteien
nicht finden frau schneider herr
fleischer zunächst vielleicht eine
einsatz und das ist genau dieses
kommunalpolitischen also diese city die
rede davon dass ich über das ja oft
nicht wahrgenommen fühlen weil da geht
es immer nur um die großen probleme oder
so also ich glaube dass ich so eine
ultimative neues programm haben dass man
sagen könnte den empfiehlt bei den
freien demokraten was oder bei der afg
sondern eher dass da wirklich so ein
konkrete straßenbau etc also wirklich
ein fest für die bürger beteiligen augen
also ja das würde ich sagen
fleischer ist das ein bundesweiter trend
also könnte das sein dass die freie
wähler in bayern sind sicher im landtag
vereinzelte abgeordnete haben sie durch
übertritte in anderen bundesländern
gewonnen jetzt rheinland pfalz der
zweite landtag könnte das sein dass sich
da eine neue partei beginnt zu
etablieren
du hast ein bisschen natürlich so eine
anti etablierten partei gibt es aber
auch jetzt echte konkurrenz jeweils um
bunten das ist ehrlich das ticket auf
dem die afg läuft also gegen die da oben
und was nicht ist es sehr schwer muss
man sagen parteien vor allem bundesweit
zu etablieren
da haben die väter des grundgesetzes
mütter des grundgesetzes einiges dafür
getan dass das dass das ein langer weg
ist dass man bei der bundestagswahl
antreten
es hängt von der bindungskraft der cdu
ich denke das sind doch wähler die diese
feiern wähler wählen die eigentlich in
dem spektrum cdu/csu zu hause sind also
etwas was die cdu weiter schwächt weil
jemand der um bürgerliche wähler erst
recht nicht die spd das sieht sieht man
auch in rheinland pfalz es schwächt die
cdu
und wenn laschet als parteivorsitzender
nicht in der lage ist das kann
eigentlich ziemlich gut wenn eine partei
zusammenzuhalten
wenn das nicht gelingt und wenn ihr die
strahlkraft für die wählerinnen und
wähler nicht hat dann kann es durchaus
sein dass die freien wähler gewisse
chancen haben als eine liberal
konservative partei wir ernähren und dem
ende dieser sendung ich würde von ihnen
allen gerne wissen was ist denn das was
jetzt bleibt von diesem wahltag beginnen
einmal mit ihnen herr fleischhauer ja
das schöne ist finde ich was sich zeigt
ist wie volatil die sache ist das hat
sich ja prantl auch angesprochen
jemand der wie laschet zum beispiel die
band so vor drei vier monaten noch
gesagt hat er habe doch eigentlich in
der krise versagt er habe zu sehr
geschwankt
viel zu sehr immer wieder die interessen
der wirtschaft betont habe gar nicht so
richtig entschieden den kurs vertreten
wie der bayerische ministerpräsident
vielleicht ist das übrigens dinge die
jetzt im wenn wir auch die
bundestagswahl zu gehen im september
wenn wir gesagt die ökonomischen folgen
viel sichtbarer werden wenn überall in
deutschen innenstädten plötzlich die
ladengeschäfte leer sind wo man sagt ja
guck mal der laschet er hat irgendwie
der hat das mit im blick gehabt der hat
der hat die interessen schon auch der
wirtschaft mit gesehen wieder das ist
das ist ja dass wenn man so will ich
glaube wirklich spannend wird ein
spannendes jahr wird ein spannender
wahlkampf und sofern wir haben auch noch
mal auch nur mal einen anderen blick auf
die auf die einzelnen politiker und
unter den gegebenen umständen ist armin
laschet dem was das beste was immer ob
die spd die cdu war schneider ihr
resümee dieses welttags ich glaube auch
dass man tatsächlich noch nie in sonnen
bei der bundestagswahl gegangen sind was
eben klar ist diese umstände sind
einfach nicht berechenbar und da kann
eben ein politiker jetzt forschung sagt
wir einsparen der irgendwie umfragen
könig war und jetzt wirklich irgendwie
am boden liegt was die umfragen angeht
und auch generell oder weiß es nicht
also ich glaube dass man sich auf gar
nichts festlegen kann aber ich teile die
ansicht man fleischer was armin laschet
angeht nämlich dass er auch schon
irgendwie in corona dingen sich früher
schon post eröffnungen gescholten wurde
jetzt das irgendwie
quasi mogis sich dafür einzusetzen
könnte ihm aber auch in sand natürlich
auch die füße fallen eben man weiß es
nicht das ist das resümee und herbert
pressl steht noch aus das interessante
für mich ist dass sich jedenfalls bei
diesen beiden landtagswahlen kraftprotz
wie sie so wieder gern zeigt nicht
auszahlt beide kandidaten sind nicht die
die die großen die autorität autorität
spielen und die sich aufplustern sondern
die versuchen pragmatisch das war das
heute ein paar mal gefallen und groß
umarmen zu sein und das hat sich
ausgezahlt und das kann durchaus sein
dass sich laschet denn heute noch viele
belächeln hier in diese richtung
entwickelt dieser bundestagswahlkampf
wird auch ein persönlichkeitsentwicklung
wahlkampf
okay das nehmen wir jetzt als
schlusswort für diesen wahltag ich darf
mich bei ihnen bedanken für diese
interessante debatte liebe zuschauer
liebe zuschauer wenn sie der fortgang
dieses wahlabends interessiert darf ich
sie hinweisen auf unsere zusammenfassung
des wahltages die ist kurz nach halb elf
22 uhr 30 22 uhr 35 mit den neuesten
hochrechnungen mit wählerwanderungen und
den reaktionen aller parteien und bei
uns geht es jetzt weiter mit einer
interessanten dokumentation über
naturparadiese im südwesten bleiben sie
sind
[Musik]